First let's talk a little bit
about camera calibration.
There are two different
types of camera calibration.
First is a geometric calibration,
where we basically are interested when
we look at a 3D scene is how each and
every pixel in the real world
is relating to directions,
angles, shapes, you know, any kind of
geometric information in the real world.
So that requires us to now
calibrate the camera and
the location of the camera with respect
to the scenes and objects in a scene, so
we can actually get more 3D information.
That's geometric.
Of course, we're also interested,
remember from our earlier lectures,
to be able to capture radiometric,
photometric, information from
a scene you know, like reflectances and
scattering of light information.
Here, basically,
we're interested in each and
every pixel related to the radiance
amounts in the real world.
You know, what's happening in a scene?
What's the exact radiance
value at any point in a scene?
How can we capture it
onto a pixel in an image?
Again, this is the whole
pipeline we just saw,
where we basically want to be able
to go from l all the way to i.
Now, we study this a little
bit when we did panaromas.
Sometimes, we might not have ability
to capture everything in a 3D world
directly from the sensors so
what we want to do now is take a little
bit of a data-driven approach.
Basically, that suggests
is let's actually do this
by looking at a bunch of images, not
just one image, and use that information
as to how things change when I
take a bunch of different images.
So, for example, here,
I may have a color pattern,
which tells me everything else about
it but I could take a color pattern,
a checkered pattern, and
move it around and as I move it around,
if knowing a little bit more about the
information in that scene, in this case,
of course, the exact nature of the
structure pattern associated here and
if I look at it from the same camera,
I should be able to kind of now get
different data, at different points.
That basically suggests is that
now I can get how pixel relates to
the geometry in a scene by just looking
at a whole lot of other images.
Well, the same thing is true
in the case of photometric.
This was relevant when we looked
at the whole case of paranomas.
This is more relevant in the kind of
world of HDR, where basically now we're
trying to relate is how the radiance of
any point on the scene is accounting for
a specific pixel intensity and we do
this by calibrating a camera by getting
a lot of data by the same scene
by having different images.
Remember, again, these were both issues
that help us when we start thinking
about concepts like epsilon photography.